Nick says that a woman like you
should have just After High School
focused on being a mother Fair okay
um you're 30. yeah you're accomplished
you went to college
you're gorgeous thank you you're smart
you're intelligent you're going to make
a great wife someday Nick believes it
should have been sooner rather than
later but you're on your own time frame
why is Nick wrong that you're actually
a happy healthy beautiful person and
you're living your your life that you
want to live yeah well first talk about
just briefly you know my grandmother
never made it past third grade she came
from Guatemala and for her you know the
fact that she could never learn and and
even read or write to
a a substantial amount
uh was really personal to her because
with education that provided Freedom you
know some education is something that
can never be taken away from you this is
your mother whether my grandmother okay
and your mother for her so for her it
was so important that her children were
educated because she knew that education
equaled Freedom it meant that something
could never take that away from you man
or woman and so when my mom and my
grandmother came from Guatemala to the
United States
you know my mother worked three jobs to
to come here learned English at night to
be educated to be a woman of worth
and uh that really mattered she ended up
being a teacher and uh really being able
to to be somebody and you know I find
that really offensive that you don't
believe that women should have the
education or the freedom because there
are a lot of women who would do anything
to be able to read a book and you laugh
but it's it's sad women can't read is
that what you're saying well I'm saying
that there are some women in some
countries that can't read
but it's a question of should they have
secondary education should they pursue a
degree and when you say education is
freedom I went to school for two
semesters before I dropped out I went to
school with a girl who borrowed her
entire tuition
for four years getting an IR degree two
hundred thousand dollars in debt for for
an IR degree for a liberal arts degree
is that freedom
isn't that isn't that anecdotal because
I know a ton of dudes in student loan
debt as well they're doing nothing with
their life it's an example it's an
example I know but the point one good
example but you agree there's millions
of guys and girls useless don't they
have the freedom to make the mistake I
mean I think that is part of the
American way to make the mistake yeah
and nobody's saying nobody has the
freedom to go to college or something
like that but the point is on the
statement specifically that education
equals freedom I don't necessarily buy
that getting a college degree is the
ticket that it used to be so everyone
needs to go to college to get Freedom
why are you saying that women in
particular shouldn't go to college and
they should be look no no let me let me
explain I think also too that women can
have it all and I think this construct
of you have to choose this career you
have to choose to be go going to college
you over having a family I'd love to
have a family one day I'd love to be
married someday and I think you can have
it all and I don't think that you have
to choose between this lifestyle of
either or why do you say that women
can't have it all and I'm gonna come to
you Amy then I'm gonna come to you Nema
I promise you can't have it all because
the clock's ticking and you know you're
30 and I don't mean it to get personal
but of course women there's an age after
which they can't have kids there's an
age after which it's much more difficult
for them to have kids that's just
biology I've been out of college I'll
let you finish I know you want to rip my
face off but I let you finish and so the
point is is that when women go to
College full-time or they have a
full-time job they can't be a mother
because a mother is a full-time job so
that means that if they are having kids
guess who's not around for eight hours
during the day where do they put the
baby for eight hours during the day do
they just stuff them in a box somewhere
gotta send them to the gate to daycare
somebody has to take care of the kids
just because you're the one that's not
doing it doesn't mean it's not a
full-time job so no you cannot have it
all without making sacrifices and the
problem is working women will have a kid
they'll prioritize their career this is
what happens in many cases
and who is the one who is forced to pay
the price who for this sacrifice and
time it's the kid it's a kid that
doesn't have the mother for those eight
hours a day when their mom's at work
it's the kid who mom can't go to the
game mom can't pick you up when you're
sick from school mom can't do x y and z
so actually we have a short life we have
to make decisions in time nobody can
have everything of everything nobody can
have it all we have to make decisions
which means sacrifice and the problem
that is going on if women want to work
their whole life and never have kids I
don't think that's good for them I don't
think that's fulfilling but worse still
is you have women that are promiscuous
which is a mortal sin they'll wind up
having kids often become a single mom
and even if they're not the kids wind up
in daycare and the point is is it's just
a very selfish lifestyle people should
put their family first that's the most
important let me ask Sammy because Amy's
been quiet and Nema come to you and then
everyone believe me everyone's gonna get
tons of times to talk I guarantee you
um you're saying that that um
in regards to women working did you go
to college Amy uh yeah my associates in
Justice and legal I dropped it out uh
but I I agree with you to some degree
but I don't think anyone can really have
it all it's only the top one percent
someone exceptional in any field to
really have it all so yes you can but
will everybody no it's unlikely so I
understand both sides of the arguments I
think if a woman really wants to do it
and she can make that happen but you're
absolutely correct that is not going to
come without sacrifice and I don't think
you can put a hundred percent into both
things you can be all in on something
but like you can be all in on multiple
things but that means that one thing at
a time you have to be giving 100 of your
focus through that thing so that is
going to be time away from your children
that is going to have some type of an
impact on them so I think that this is
something to certainly keep in mind when
we are trying to talk about the
traditional values that we want to
reinstill in society but that doesn't
necessarily mean we have to legislate it
or anything like that which you said you
never even said that in the first place
are you are you um like what are you
doing to sort of reinforce you're 28.
smart attractive same you guys are the
same people smart attractive late 20s
early 30s no man no kids tons of people
in your DMs here's Nick
who's basically like yeah I mean if you
could sum up in one sentence your advice
for them what would it be
don't go to school have kids stop having
sex have kids with your husband and you
mentioned that being promiscuous is
immortal sin yeah is that sex before
marriage yeah so what happens then go to
hell so they're going to hell if they
don't repent yeah so all they have to do
is do what you have to go to confession
I'm sorry so do you firmly believe that
let's say these two girls have had sex
out of wedlock will go to hell well I
mean the Catholic position is we don't
know who goes to heaven but we do
believe that adultery is a mortal sin
pre-marital sex is a mortal sin and
Mortal sins mean their grave and with
full consent breaking the ten
commandments so what's your advice to
Young Amy over here my advice would be
find a husband who's going to take care
of you and love you and cherish you and
have kids and that's the most beautiful
thing that's actually what I want I got
into a debate with Brendan Carter about
this recently because I've been a person
like I've traveled like I've moved
across the world made a lot of money
I've done the things and one thing I can
strongly attest to is it never made me
truly happy or fulfilled you get the
dirty you get the dopamine rush but then
with goals it's always on to the next
thing dopamine is highly highly
addictive and so people have this end in
mind where they're like when I get here
I'll be happy but then there's always
something else that comes up
um for women I in in this debate we
actually brought up that
um the chemical of oxytocin is a
chemical that can only be induced it
necessitates the presence of another
person you need to be giving to another
person need to be pouring into them
providing value to them and I think the
easiest way to do that for a woman is
through a family so my mindset has
completely changed uh completely are you
ready to quit your job well my goal is
to get married and have kids I mean I
just got out of a relationship so I know
I need to heal from that I don't want to
bring any of that into my next
relationship but the next guy I'm with I
want that to be the person I'm with the
rest of my life I want to have kids I
want a family I want those Traditional
Values okay more than like anything
honestly so if you like that clip click
right here to watch another or if you
want to watch the entire saucecast click
right here
foreign